the State of the Union address a grand
stage for the US president to speak
directly to a national audience about
what he has accomplished and what still
needs to be done but what is the State
of the Union after two years of Trump's
presidency my State of the Union I think
in pretty good shape yeah and look
forward to hearing what the president
has to say during the State of the Union
and the economy and everything and
hopefully to focus a little bit more on
bipartisanship working together I think
it's in bad shape at the talk in the
White House I think we have an
incompetent possibly insane person if
they had if the executive department
gets the same old stuff that's why I
expect you know money for the border you
know you know the other stuff he wants
that can't afford choosing greatness
that's the official White House theme
for Donald Trump's address to Congress
you as president plans to strike a
conciliatory tone and deliver a call for
unity in his speech but in many ways it
might be too late the country and
Congress are divided along party lines
and the Democrats are determined to make
sure that Trump remains a one-term
president rebuilding the country's
infrastructure lowering the cost of
prescription drugs these are issues both
parties could agree on but instead they
fight over Trump's planned border wall
the topic is expected to be front and
center of trumps address to Congress
with no indication of either side giving
an inch we will be looking at a national
emergency because I don't think
anything's gonna happen
I think the Democrats don't want mortar
security and when I hear them talking
about the fact that walls are immoral
and wolves don't work they know they
work Trump has suggested there will be a
major announcement in his speech but
then again he might be just trying to
raise expectations ahead of the address
he is difficult to predict says Elaine
Kay mark author and former aide to
President Bill Clinton
we don't know if he'll stick to the
script and also remember that behind him
sit the vice-president who is by the
Constitution the president of the Senate
and the Speaker of the House Nancy
Pelosi so I don't know what kinds of
expressions Nancy Pelosi might make as
he's making this speech but that will be
interesting too House Speaker Nancy
Pelosi will be visible in nearly every
camera shot her presence is evidence of
the newfound power of the Democratic
Party and a reminder of Trump's
struggles to adapt to a divided
government in Washington
you